good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to Columbia University my name
is John midscale i'm very happy to greet
you here on behalf of both the
university the Polish and Ukrainian
studies programs and also on behalf of
all of our co-sponsors and I'm very
happy to say that we have a relatively
large number of institutions that
decided that this was something that
they wanted to get involved in our
meeting today is not the first time that
the Ukrainians and poles have gathered
in New York City to talk about things
that interest the both of them certainly
in places like the the Ukrainian
institutes the various Ukrainian
institutes downtown there have been
meetings like this in the past in the
1970s the 1980s here at Columbia not so
long ago in October of 1999 we had a
conference entitled breaking the cycle
contemporary polish ukrainian relations
in historical context and since then
columbia and mark von hagen the director
of the ukrainian studies program has
been steadily building ukrainian
offerings just as we have been steadily
building you polish offerings here
through various means on the Ukrainian
side the petrol oxic visiting
professorship the establishment of an
endowment to support a permanent chair
in Ukrainian history which we hope will
happen in our lifetime and funds aimed
at supporting instruction in Ukrainian
language language and literature have
all been set up in the last few years
and that means that Columbia is moving
toward very much toward a stronger
presence in Ukraine and on subjects of
interest to Ukrainians and also to
Americans who are interested in in
Ukraine on the polish side the
establishment of the atom it's gavage
fund to support polish language in
richer in 1999 the establishment of a
Polish studies and dominant just last
year in 2003 aimed at creating a chair
in Polish studies at the School of
International and public affairs and
finally the coaster school foundation
semper Polonia foundation distinguished
visiting professorship in Polish studies
something which will not fit on one card
when you go to read it it has also been
created here at Columbia and the first
incumbent the first holder of that
physician is Professor me how bosque
who's sitting in the front row here and
who will chair the first session this
afternoon and for the last four years we
here at Columbia have been very happy
co-sponsors of the large and
well-organized conference on Ukraine's
quest for mature nation and statehood
which is held annually in Washington DC
it's a slightly different kind of a
forum than we have here today but
something that is important because it
draws in the policymakers in Washington
into things that are of interest in our
part of the world and you can't get
enough of that in a place like
Washington DC so as you can see we've
been sort of busy here at Columbia and
today we and our colleagues and the
Polish and Ukrainian communities have
gotten together to organize this meeting
which we think will be a great success
our immense gratitude goes to the
organization's who co-funded co-funded
and or sponsored exhibitions at this
meeting the exhibitions that you will
see at some point during the day today
in our lobby and those institutions that
are cooperating in this fashion are the
first security Federal Savings Bank of
Chicago the Kosciusko foundation the
Pilsudski Institute the Polish American
Ukrainian cooperation initiative which
is funded by
and USAID grant the polish consulate in
New York City the self-reliance federal
credit union of New York the semper
Polonia foundation in Warsaw the taras
shevchenko scientific society here in
New York the Ukrainian Congress
Committee of America the Ukrainian free
academy in America and the Ukrainian
Institute of America did I leave anybody
out this will be a first these are all
very good organizations we thank them
for getting interested in something that
we've been thinking about for a very
long time and of course whenever you
need to do something you need to rely on
people to do that and that's why our
thanks goes also to our staff here at
Columbia their hard work brought you all
here the people that are at the top of
the list so to speak or Maria so
Nowitzki of the Ukrainian Studies
program here at Columbia who is
somewhere in the audience sort of
flitting around doing things and Kevin
hallinan of the East Central European
Center in the Institute for the Study of
Europe standing in the back of the room
I would be remiss and it would not be
nice of me if I didn't also thank our
distinguished colleague from New York
University and Ukrainian Congress
Committee Walter Zaretsky Walter are you
here